beating Donald Trump is the floor it is
not the ceiling with only five minutes
each to speak the candidates had to get
to the heart of their pitches quickly
we're not gonna win by playing it safe
or promising a return to normal we are
where we are because normal broke
everything I propose comes to one
central question who does this
government work for a new poll shows big
gains by senator Elizabeth Warren and
South Bend Indiana mayor Pete Buddha
judge they along with Biden and senator
Bernie Sanders were the only ones to
crack double digits Warren armed with
new momentum took a subtle jab at the
front-runner I'm not spending my time
with high-dollar donors and with
corporate lobbyists I'm spending my time
with you and she wasn't the only one I
don't think there is room in our party
for a Democratic candidate who does not
support women's full reproductive
freedom the former vice president came
under fire last week for backing the
Hyde Amendment a long-standing law
blocking federal funding of abortion he
changed his position
a day later there are some
well-intentioned Democrats and
candidates who believe that the best way
forward is a middle ground strategy that
approach is not just bad public policy
but it is a failed political strategy
the Iowa Democratic caucus isn't
scheduled to take place until February
third eight months from now but it is
the first nominating contest in the
presidential primaries which explains
why 19 Democratic candidates would all
hit the state at once this far out yeah
it's the time when I have otres feel
very special thank you very much Nancy
everybody wants to see them